in the last video we talked about the
scenario where a company for whatever
reason
it just couldn't pay its debt holder so
this is the debt holders right here this
is the debt or the liabilities
it couldn't pay its debt holders it went
into bankruptcy and it was determined
that these assets that it had right here
that no it made no sense operating them
as a company and then the bankruptcy
court essentially just decided to
liquidate it and we learned that the
debt holders were actually more senior
to the equity holders and they get paid
first and if there wasn't enough money
to pay all of the debt holders then the
equity holders got nothing and that was
called this equity and that was called
so that was a chapter seven
and we're just focusing on the corporate
world right now maybe we'll do personal
soon so that's chapter seven liquidation
that was the last video
and in that case and i think that's what
most people associate when when you when
you say that a company has gone bankrupt
that it'll just disappear that people
just say okay these assets don't make
any sense they can't pay these guys
we're just going to take these into
possession by the courts and then just
liquidate the assets but that that that
raises a kind of an obvious question of
well what if these assets are are worth
something you know what if i sell a sox
website and stocks have gotten even more
popular and the only problem is i just
can't pay all of the interest that i owe
on the on the debt right maybe for
whatever reason i took out a really
crazy loan that was variable rate or for
some reason i had to pay back some loans
because i messed you know my and i'll
talk more about covenants and things
like that covenants are pretty much a
bunch of rules that the debt holders say
look you're good uh as but if any of
these x y or z things happen we can take
you into bankruptcy and we could force
you into bankruptcy so maybe because of
that i'm in bankruptcy but it's
determined that these assets right here
are actually worth more as an operating
entity than they are if you were to
liquidate them and you know a good
example might be i don't know a car
company right so let's say let's
actually take this example as a car
company because it's very it's very
salient to our
to at least it was i've heard a lot less
about the auto bailouts but uh it was
very still in the end of last year so
let's say that you know these are car
factories
car factories and you know land and
whatever else
and if we're the debt holders and let's
say it goes into bankruptcy and let's
say it only went into bankrupt let's say
this is generating cash and i'll tell
you i'll teach you in a future video how
do you see what is the cash being
generated by the assets
and then you have to subtract out you
know the cash that has to be used to pay
the debt holders because you're paying
interest and then what's left over for
equity and i'll show you how to do that
on an income statement but let's say
that this is generating a lot of cash
right it should bring in a good bit of
cash but let's say you know these guys
eat up interest right so some of the
cash
will go to the debt holders is interest
and let's say for whatever
reason either interest rates went up or
they had a bad quarter or a bad year and
they just didn't generate enough cash
let's say they couldn't pay off one of
the debt holders and that debt holder
says hey
you couldn't pay my interest payment or
you can pay the principal payment i'm
taking you into
bankruptcy
right taking the bankruptcy so it goes
into bankruptcy and in this situation
where we'll
immediately we realize that you know it
makes no sense to shutter this assets if
we were to just shut down the factory
and lay off the employees we're going to
get nothing for these assets because you
know the land is in in a part of the
country where you know there's no
obvious buyer for the land uh empty car
factory is pretty much useless
especially when the other people in the
industry are no uh in no mood to buy the
factories from you so everyone decides
it's in their best interest to keep this
thing running so what happens is is that
the debtor stays in possession of the
assets so you can kind of view the
debtors the equity holders and the
management of the company so they stay
in possession of the assets
and what actually what happens is
because you know these guys didn't have
enough cash to pay off their debt
holders what happens is they take on a
new loan called a debtor in possession
loan and this new loan is the most
senior loan
it's called dip financing it's actually
a great business although it's become
scarce recently
dip financing
it's a great business because you're at
the top of the stack
you're you're more senior than even the
senior guys
it's called dip financing debtor in
possession
financing and what this provides is a
company with some kind of cushion cash
so that it can keep operating so it can
keep the lights on
so it's essentially a debt it's just
very senior type of debt
and it happens once a company has
entered bankruptcy right and this
bankruptcy that we're going to talk
about is chapter 11 chapter
chapter 11
restructuring
in a chapter 11 restructuring you keep
operating the company and what you want
to do is you want to essentially i mean
you might do some things on the left
hand side of the cup of the equation you
might want to sell off some of the
assets and all that but we won't go into
that most of what you do is you
rearrange this side
of the balance sheet
and this is why you probably you know
the every airlines have some of them
have gone into bankruptcy multiple times
but they still exist it's not like when
you go into bankruptcy the company just
disappears the assets will persist and
all of this gets reorganized on this
side and a lot of times when someone
goes into chapter 11 and then they go
they you know they come out of it and
they go back into it they call that
chapter 22 and then chapter 33 and i
think i think you get the idea so anyway
what happens in chapter 11.
so the assets essentially it becomes
kind of uh the bankruptcy court takes
over
and they hire some investment they'll
get the better and possession financing
so that the company has some cash to
operate pay the bills and pay the
employees and whatever else the company
keeps operating as it always would so it
can pay its suppliers and and operate as
a regular business
and then all of these guys
hire a bunch of lawyers
all of these guys hire a bunch of
lawyers
and they start
and well i'll include just these guys
and they start negotiating with each
other and essentially there'll be a a a
bank associated with the bankruptcy
court whose whole job and it's all part
of the negotiation is to value this and
it's often you know maybe maybe this
debtor right here he'll hire one bank
this debtor will hire one bank maybe the
management will hire another bank and
everyone's going to come up with
bankruptcy plans but bankruptcy plans
are usually
of you know one or or more
varieties it's essentially just saying
well you know we need to value these
assets right we're not selling it so
we're not just going to get cash we're
going to hire some bankers we'll do a
lot of videos on that in the future and
they're just going to say you know based
on the prospects of this company how
fast it's growing or how fast it's not
growing or how much cash is generated a
year they're going to assign a value to
it so let's say
let's say that this guy
up here he hires a banker and this
banker says let's say let me let me
let's say this this was originally
same situation for this was 10 million
let's say that the liabilities were 6
million and that the original equity was
4 million right
and let's say these bankers
evaluate the business they make detailed
models they you know they take it into
context with the current macro
environment and they say you know what i
think this company is actually only
worth five million dollars
i think this company is worth five
million dollars
and given that it's worth five million
dollars and and we think that it can
sustain that it can sustain i don't know
only it can't you know it's only worth
five million dollars and there's no way
that it can pay interest on six million
dollars of debt
right it doesn't have enough cash to
generate six million dollars of debt we
think it can afford two million dollars
of debt
right
so what will happen is the new company
and this is just a plan and then once
you have a plan then everyone has to
vote on it and there's things called
cram downs and we'll do that in more
detail but the plan will say you know
what
the assets are worth five million
dollars so i thought i was using the
square tool
uh undo
this plan might say you know those
assets are worth five million dollars
so assets are worth five million dollars
and the company can only handle two
million dollars in debt not six million
dollars of debt
not six million dollars of debt so now
you can only handle two million dollars
of debt
and then there will be
three million dollars
left of equity
right and i'll call this the new equity
because sometimes this can get confusing
so let's just say for a second and let
and i want you to think about it what's
everyone's incentive this guy up here
his incentive is to value the company as
lowly as possible right
because then he gets more of the company
i think that'll be clear to you in a
second and this guy's incentive to say
no this company's worth a lot so all of
you guys are going to get paid back and
then i get what's left over and and
you're probably asking what do you get
paid back if there's not not actual for
not liquidating it and the answer is the
new shares of the company so what
happens is
is that this
stock gets let's say this this this plan
gets passed
this plan right here
in this situation these guys up here
were the most senior right let's say
there was two million dollars of senior
debt up here
let me write that in a different color
and it gets very
there's two million dollars of senior
debt up here so what they'll do is
they'll actually get two million dollars
of the new debt
their most senior
and then all of these other these other
four million dollars who are more junior
let me see if i can color it in i know
this is hard to read
these other four million guys instead of
getting instead of getting any kind of
cash or any kind of debt securities for
having been owed this money they'll get
the new stock so they'll get three
million dollars of new stock and let me
see if i can draw that in
they'll get the three million dollars of
new stock so this three million of new
equity
will go to these guys
and this unsecured guy down here he's
not going to get as much equity he'll be
he'll be impaired a little bit and the
old equity guys the stocks going to go
to zero they're not going to get
anything so the old shareholders of
their company are wiped out they go to
zero and essentially
the debt holders
the debt holders become the new
shareholders of the company
these guys become the new shareholders
company and you'll often see when a
company goes into bankruptcy but it's
getting reorganized you'll often see
some people start to buy up this debt or
these bonds right here you'll see people
buy up these bonds
because they want to be the new equity
holders they want to when the company
emerges from bankruptcy let's say that
this is how it emerges from bankruptcy
they want to be these guys the new
equity holders because usually when you
value it you want to undervalue a little
bit at least these i know i've overdrawn
this picture a little bit too much but
the debt guys especially the senior debt
guys they want to assign they want to be
safe they want to say you know what
we've already been hurt by this company
they're already not paying our debt we
want to assign as low a possible value
to the company as possible right in this
case five million dollars so that we
make sure you know hopefully this the
company ends up being worth 10 million
dollars again in which case these guys
right here
in which case these guys right here make
out like bandits right if the company
was really worth 10 million but the
bankruptcy court values at 5 million
these guys get all of the all of the
shares of the company these guys get
wiped out even though the company really
was worth something so let's say the
company emerges from bankruptcy like
this but it actually turns out there
were 10 million dollars that let's say a
year later the company starts doing well
again and let's say that someone could
value the company again at 10 million
now it only has 2 million dollars of
debt
and now you have 8 million dollars worth
of equity so these guys you know maybe
they were owed two or three million
dollars before they got three million
dollars of the new equity they might
have made out like bandits because now
all of a sudden that equity could be
worth a lot that's not always the case
but that's how that's the view from the
debt holders point of view
the equity holders you can imagine they
don't want to be left with nothing
they'll say they'll hire their own
bankers and their bankers they'll
probably submit a plan that says no no
no this company it's worth at least 8
million it's worth at least 8 million
so you know it's up here eight million
and we think it can handle i don't know
four million dollars of debt
so they'd want a scenario like this
where they think the company's worth
eight million
eight million it can handle four million
dollars worth of debt and so it has four
million dollars worth of equity
and of course the first six million
dollars of the value so the four million
dollars of debt
and then two million of the equity will
go to the debt holders right
because they were owed six million
dollars to begin with
and then what's left over
which is essentially so this is two
million of equity and then you'd have
two million of equity here this will go
this two million of new equity right
this is the new shares of the company
will be given to the old shareholders of
the company so that's what the
shareholders want i know this gets a
little confusing but it's all about
it all ends up being
valuing the assets as you emerge from
bankruptcy you say you know it's
generating cash it's worth something and
then you pay people off according to
seniority
and first you pay them off you say okay
i still owe you some money but this
company can't can't support six million
dollars that it can now support two
million and whatever is else whatever is
left people are paid with actually
shares
new shares of the company not the old
shares so the old shares will go to zero
so you can imagine a world where gm goes
bankrupt right now the shares of gm go
to zero
gm old goes to zero
but the assets keep operating and that's
why some people are a little bit
misleading in this whole automotive
bankruptcy debate they're kind of using
scare tax to say oh if gm goes bankrupt
that these assets are just going to
disappear no they'll just keep operating
if it makes sense to operate them
they'll keep operating the only people
who lose big
are the old equity holders and then some
of the unsecured the more junior levels
of debt will probably lose some money
but if the assets are worth operating
they'll continue to operate and if the
people if it makes sense to have them
employed they'll keep working see in the
next video